what is a believe nation it is just
seven o'clock in the morning on I don't
know what that is but they it's sage
seventh day here in Toronto and I'm
taking you with
[Music]
Paige is one of my clients we've had
Stephen Kelly on the channel lots and
lots and lots and lots and lots of times
the visionary CEO or our favourite CEOs
in the world and every year they put on
these huge events celebrate
entrepreneurship and this year they have
one in Toronto so I am going and have
some fun let's do it so typically state
summit has been in one main city and
last year I want top two years and women
spoke this year they're going to
multiple cities so I'm here in Toronto
for their tour which is awesome and Lily
and I are also going to be taking part
in it you have sessions today in morale
mentoring through the entrepreneurs that
are showing up so pretty come I love
mentoring and helping others and with
Lily the first time sees limits though
citizens
[Music]
just a little unit we'll find her look
who I found
it's Lily just filming oh no your says
new to stage look at that alright maybe
people will be nice did you believe I
got here early rooms about to get full
we got our front row seats look at that
[Music]
all right just came out of the oh is
that keynote session part Lilly was
dancing a lot kind of and it goes the
trouble maker the troublemaker
Rebecca Coleman control I didn't get to
do the session on ABC social media here
today hips number one tip if you want to
associate and keep doing it was what is
consistency like every day once a day
maybe not for every single network but
yeah
girl like 90% of the bottle right there
or oh right there you just gotta keep
doing it we're going to pull one
everyone mixed up Julie and I are doing
our mentoring session yes we are
Lily Lily
we're going to go we're going to help
imaginary let me say all right lunch
time an Egyptian food so I had a fan of
the channel Sebastian come up and each
of the conversation we're having and he
is trying to write a book enchanted with
business and wanted T fact on your one
word how to fight his his life what he's
doing and we have really who is the your
one word coach so she just started a
session with him and I'm excited to see
how it turns out
I'm ENGLISH cron has a big great to
become another Clinton alright that end
up being a crazy day one I was be
rolling Lily doing some coaching
sessions and then I got bombarded with
people want to meet and get advice and
so didn't you have time set the camera
no pre-roll no nothing just helping
entrepreneurs one story that was often
was there was a girl who took the
business in saw my youtube channel
watched every video and was thinking
about coming to summer I got an email
caught us about accounting I'm not
interested and then saw that I was
speaking at the event that I got to go
I'm going to go I'm going to go with the
oven and that felt good and I hope I
hope she got value I hope she got good
value hoping it let her down there but
it's great to connect to frame rate to
help some entrepreneurs I've got to
leave really still doing some mentoring
I'm going to go pick up haters in school
and then we back again tomorrow for day
two or six I'd help launch all right
they to upstage summit this is Alex Alex
is a message of the day the big message
is hustle even when you don't want to
hustle even when you don't want it's
good it's a good recipe really how I get
holidays not coming today but time had
not lilies doing a session I'm doing a
couple we have some fun all right so I
made it in got my coffee back in my
mentor lounge here got my nametag
I'm supposed to do one section today but
apparently there are there's a lineup
people want to chat
so they smush three people into my one
session you know my break and talked
with somebody else too so I love it I
don't like breaks like let's go you want
to help entrepreneurs I'm here I'm
talking ready to do it what until either
they come and then first session I don't
know if I'm going to have time to shoot
any fuel while I'm making it maybe Lily
will we'll see but you know help
entrepreneurs
five at a couple good sessions just
found a friend of mine Roger Pierce
gonna go say hi
he's about to give a presentation
it's mr. Roger Pierce there is a van REO
what's that mean
or during professional judgment close
more sales following the intelligent
what's your favorite step the cloves
overcoming those nasty objection
sign the line that is not what with the
piece of value that you could drop and
believe nation there unclosing don't be
afraid to ask for the state and you
surprised so many entrepreneurs River
don't want to ask because when the
perceived after sale of Digimon
I like so lunch is Asia Asian chicken
noodle something beef halal burrito
although I don't see a burrito maybe I
missed that in a fruit stick
yeah and I've had a couple more great
session
Austin's I hear so many great
entrepreneurs olive on how it's great
helping them out but I'm leek they were
over booking me and then on my breaks
who wanted me to meet more people and
I'm leaving more people come up to ask
questions of the guys we go I gotta go
so I'm heading off to the media center
upstairs supposed to do a Facebook live
hangout with Stephen and I think I have
a little bit time and then doing the
live YouTube hang out with you guys so
up to that this is where we're going to
do it
we got to set up in Stephen in the
middle C in tower on one side City Hall
on the other excited with some Facebook
lives great to have a live broadcast
from st. Simon in Toronto with there's a
couple thousand entrepreneurs business
fathers here and we'll tell you a bit
about safe summit might go from walk-ins
go and see the show floor during the
broadcast as well but most of all I'm
really proud privileged to be joined by
an old friend amazing entrepreneur
author inspire many genome and you see a
money's Channel Evan Carmichael so Evans
great to be in your home city tablet I
love them glad you guys came here on the
same summer tour it's great I can just
wake up and come right downtown the same
summers awesome
all right we had a fun Facebook live
hangout got to explore the floor as well
go chat with some entrepreneurs next up
is our Google live hangout with you guys
just setting up here testing the
connection make sure we got a good one
and looking forward to answering your
questions
Stephens rocking some Canadian pride
we've got the Canada pin happening there
oh this H at the top to I didn't see
that little stage local top that the
cufflinks you can't see his shoes he's
got the shoes he's got the tattoo
happening on the arm
because we keep getting materia
upside-down sorry goes here there it is
look at that
there it is and it applies it that one
round all right we are done that was
awesome there were so many questions
coming in I couldn't keep track normally
on on the hangouts that I do while the
other person's talking I'll scroll for
the questions and look to the next one
but I didn't want to look off screen all
the time and feel like I was ignoring
with C Hussein so it's going through it
but I looked at a question and then I
came back and the question was gone
because the page filled with new filled
with new questions and so it was awesome
to see the interaction loved you guys so
many great questions so much fun I just
I feel bad that people posted some
questions multiple times and I saw it
and then when I came back to read it it
was gone I went to another one so just
be persistent guys get your questions in
early and often and hopefully next time
we'll be able to answer them that's it
for me it's been another amazing tip
summit we're going to head home touch
Nina do our work out and enjoy the rest
of my week so appreciate you guys for
watching hope you enjoy if you'll see
you at a event soon and just one quick
thing if you're going to event and your
you want to meet people get in there
fast you want to go talk to a speaker
you be there before the speaker goes
onstage you want to have a mentoring
session my first mentoring session was
empty nobody showed up
I spoke with Lily for 45 minutes and
then in my next mentoring session it was
all full and then the next one it's like
triple what in getting people one and
talked to me on my break and and walk
you to the next thing and it's great I'm
happy to do it I love being fully booked
I'm not complaining I love it it fuels
me but there are lots of people waiting
to or I didn't get to talk to
it bothered me because I had all this
free time before and so at this summit
of who you want to talk to you at an
event don't be shy like if your goal is
to go there and talk to them and get
their feedback on something that you're
dealing with right now don't be shy go
say hi talk to the speaker before they
go onstage because they're going to be
bombarded afterwards and if you get in
you know they're only have a couple
minutes because they're swamped is a
huge lineup for the hangouts that I just
did right did you be the first one there
you know the guy who asked the first
question I answer his question right it
was the first question in all the other
people who would join later you know
there's a chance we interchange who may
not they were rushing trying to get to
other questions so if there's something
that you want to do this or that you
want to meet and you know they're going
to be there they're doing a hangout just
show up early ask question be the first
one there it makes such a huge
difference between getting results and
not and so just to leave you in fact
guys hope you have an amazing weekend
thank you for watching thanks for all
the love I really appreciate it you guys
are the reason why I do all this and I'm
really thankful for your support in
viewership so is it for me
continue to believe in whatever your one
where it is much love guys I'll see you
soon